concrètement le chef de la police
nationale de montpellier le chef le
gradé s'est adjoint et m'a clairement
dit qu'ils ne voulaient plus dès que
notre cher et tendre maire monsieur de
la fosse ne voulait plus de sdf au
centre ville et que entre guillemets une
mesure d'éloignement du centre-ville des
sdf a été été mis en place et soi disant
aussi en arrêt préfectoral a été mise en
place
d'ailleurs je tenais juste à jerry seah
présence un ami à moi de rue et qui fait
la manche à mes côtés quasiment tous les
jours pour aller voir aussi fabrice et
de l'aider c'est possible d'aider aussi
c'est pas mal parce qu'il a quand même
là quand même trois chiens et une femme
aussi qu'ils aient enfin alors on à
grégory beaud zone et qui est avec nous
par facetime c'est le directeur de
cabinet du maire de montpellier parce
qu'on voulait en savoir un peu plus sur
cette affaire nous avait dit qu'on
enquêterait qu'on essaierait d'avoir des
personnes de la mairie
merci en tout cas grégory beaud zone est
d'être avec nous ce soir parce que c'est
que ces courageux c'est sympa d'être
avec nous merci à vous si vous êtes à la
mairie actuellement je suis à la mairie
je suis dans mon bureau comme vous
pouvez le voir je vous remercie à de
pareilles ce sujet c c'est vraiment très
important et ça les rend très bien
utiliser du temps d'antenne pour pour
évoquer cette question des sans domicile
fixe vous remercier moi aussi de
m'inviter pour pour ce sujet juste
grégory quand on entend alex qui dit que
les sdf ne sont pas les bienvenus dans
le centre-ville de montpellier est ce
que vous confirmez absolument pas bien
entendu alors même si évidemment ce que
l'on fait c'est qu'ils puissent c'est
qu'il puisse être à être hébergés bien
sûr puisque plus qu'à d'être dans la rue
ce que ce que tout le monde comprendra
très bien mais je pense et j'espère que
les propos n'ont pas été tenues alors
s'ils ont été tenus par la police
nationale il n'ya bien sûr aucun lien
avec avec michaël delafosse puisque nous
n'avons pas de le maire de volée de lien
hiérarchique avec la police nationale ce
que ce que ce que tout le monde en temps
mais je ne pense pas que ses propos
aient été tenus je le souhaite vraiment
pas on a je vous dis les choses on
on a fait beaucoup de travail sur ce
sujet on a on a augmenté
considérablement l'aide aux associations
en la matière notamment à aqualiens qui
qui qui peut qui peut accueillir alex je
pense qu'il pourra vous en parler
j'espère que calor c'est la réponse du
directeur de colo dire que les paroles
ce ne sont pas les paroles de la police
nationale manque de chance pour eux j'ai
les enregistrements de la police
nationale et les enregistrements vidéo
qui prouvent que la police nationale m'a
dit exactement les propos que je viens
de dire
on m'a parlé carrément d'embarras sur la
voie publique ont mal géré les sdf vous
allez dégagez concrètement du
centre-ville et c'était bien le chef de
la police nationale de montpellier de la
comédie qui m'a dit ça j'ai les
enregistrements vidéo et dire que quoi
il ya pas eu d oui parce que
chauffailles akwaya aqualia a eu des
subventions en plus ça serait mentir
parce que quoi il ya en ce moment même
on se je suis désolé mais on va pas dire
que que ils ont eu des subventions plus
parce que premièrement les douches
récemment un exemple le robinet était
cassé et émis une semaine à le changer
l'état de la cour de quoi lia et et pas
déployé le tas de du foyer est pas et
pas forcément des mieux et je ne vois
pas où sont les subventions que vote que
mon cher e et tendre maire monsieur de
la fosse a su faire et la grille oui
juste grégory oui on parlait aussi du
port du port du masque il a été
verbalisé cette loi pour non port du
masque pour les sdf
est ce qu est ce que vous comprenez
cette cette mesure alors de deux choses
donc déjà s'il est profond et est ont
été tenus 1 comme commune comme il leur
apporter et n'y a vraiment aucune raison
de ne pas croire ce qu'il dit un jeu
dire je ne m'arrêterai pas par la police
nationale c'est bien sûr quelque chose
que l'on nous que l'on condamné une fois
encore il n'y a pas de lien entre le
maire montpellier et et la police
nationale c'est pas nous qui tient quant
à la tête de la police nationale ce que
parce que tout le monde comprend mais
vraiment c'est ces propos sont
absolument pas ceux de michaël delafosse
ils ne correspondent absolument pas la
politique qui est menée et pour évoquer
l'augmentation que je disais ici à ses 3
lyon d'euros en scène ces implants
pauvreté qu'on a signé avec l'état et
bien sûr aller travailler que les
associations
je ne défilent pas la question là la
verbalisation je vais venir tout de
suite nos policiers municipaux ce qui
pour le coup dépendent dépendent de la
mairie ont tous et où ça aussi c'est un
peu ça peut se vérifier assez facilement
des masques qui leur promettent à
disposition des personnes qui
éventuellement n'en auraient pas alors
bien entendu les personnes qui sont
domiciliées au ccs ski à ce qui a été le
cas de monsieur voit déjà ce bois des
genres qui est tout à fait normal mais
dans le cas où ça peut arriver à des
personnes non non pas de masque on leur
en propose la verbalisation en la
matière ne vient exclusivement du fait
que la personne ici ça peut arriver sur
d'autres personnes aient refusé de me
porter ce masque que l'on opposait
enfants très bien la difficulté de se
fournir en masque je ne vais pas vous
dire que ce n'est pas un coup on sait
que c'est un budget important pour
certaines familles et ça l'est d'autant
plus quand on est en situation précaire
comme comme on l'a évoqué ici on
comprend très bien
c'est pour cela qu on distribue on a
distribué 150 mille masques gratuitement
au niveau du ccas en priorité notamment
aux populations sans domicile fixe qui
représente à peu près deux cents 200
foyers à à montpellier mais un peu plus
globalement aux 2200 personnes qui sont
domiciliées au ccs est à dire qu'ils
n'ont pas aidé à dresde adresse
personnelle on est très très vigilant
sur le sujet est vraiment pour le coup à
michaël delafosse à a toujours été verts
est très claire sur cette politique
cette politique là et notamment
je rebondis même si c'est un direct on
va on a inauguré des douches mobiles
pour pouvoir le douche permettre aux
personnes qui sont sans domicile fixe
bah alors je sais bien merci
rien parce que les classes directeur de
cabinet du maire de montpellier
en tout cas ce qu'on retient nous c'est
que alex en tout cas aujourd'hui
on a essayé voilà grâce à tout ça mine
de rien que ça se termine bien et ça
termine bien tout cas merci
grégory je sais qui est une personnalité
qui compte beaucoup pour tout alex c'est
rémi gaillard
ouais ce soir il a un message simple et
en plus il a une petite nouvelle petite
nouvelle pour toi alexandre jeu
désolé je peux pas être avec points ce
soir mais tu le sais je suis là toujours
et je serai là notamment demain à partir
de 10h30 devant le tribunal pour te
soutenir et je serai pas tout seul la
bonne nouvelle c'est que pour te
défendre carrément y aura aussi un des
plus grands cabinets d'avocats de la
ville le cabinet fung et on les remercie
et te dire pour terminer que tu sais
contrairement à ce que tu penses est ce
que tu me dis souvent c'est pas moi qui
t'ai aider je crois et j'en suis sûr que
c'est toi qui m'a aidée par ton coeur et
par ton humanité
je te souhaite le meilleur